[Music]
what's your favorite programming
language and why
I definitely Python I actually learned
to code on C and C++ and it's a lot
harder when there are sort of more
brackets and more complicated things and
I feel like Python abstracts away a lot
of that while still giving you a lot of
functionality it allows you to do a lot
of really cool machine learning things
my favorite programming language is
Python because of ease of use and speed
of development and I especially love
using pipe arch I like Python because
originally I learned how to program and
C and Python is just a lot more
high-level and it's a lot easier to use
I hate them all equal if not true I like
most programming languages lately a
great burger man Python it's a fairly
convenient language my favorite
programming though just probably c-sharp
I like it because it fixed everything
that Java did wrong but mostly it's it's
become a standard in
the gaming industry and I really love
video games I love being able to program
video games and it's a really nice easy
to use language honestly I guess I would
probably say Python which is maybe a
boring answer because I guess a lot of
people would say that but for me it's
just really easy to prototype and build
things quickly which is important in my
research I love Python
I think Python is like writing English
at times it's almost so easy to
understand for for programmers even then
when you want to do the low-level things
which is incredibly powerful
I prefer by phone because it's easy and
you can program very easily tasks and
you can see the results quite okay at
the risk of not being a programmer I do
a lot of programming in MATLAB because
that's what I know and it's very good
for controls but for a real language
I like Python I can say my least
favorite also if people people want that
is C and C++ because you make a ton of
bugs and they're possible to solve waste
your whole day
[Music]